tributes to adelson are pouring in from  local leaders governor steve sisolak  wrote in part  i was very saddened to hear of sheldon  adelson's passing  he was a man who believed in succeeded  in and invested in bold and daring ideas  that changed the state of nevada  former nevada senator and former senate  majority leader harry reid  wrote in part few people have had such a  significant impact on the hotel and  gaming industry and on nevada's economy  as sheldon adelson  he was instrument he was instrumental in  transforming las vegas into the iconic  destination it is today  allison was a big republican donor  senate majority leader and republican  mitch mcconnell said  our nation has lost a remarkable  american he climbed from sleeping on  floors during the great depression to  towering over las vegas and beyond